1500 véhicules de fret bloqué font la
queue pour se rendre en france
les britanniques eux ont peur que leur
pays ne soit confrontée à des pénuries
alimentaires
la faute à des restrictions de voyage
mis en place pour ralentir la
propagation d'une nouvelle variante du
coronavirus ma famille matin mes enfants
ma fille ma femme et vous savez c'était
spécial c'était censé être très rapide
et j'ai passé au royaume uni 10 minutes
à une station essence et 20 minutes au
point de déchargement ce n'est pas long
mais maintenant je dois attendre deux
jours ici dans le port je me sens très
mal
je suis fatigué déçu je n'ai pas de mots
que nous est-il arrivé c'est
inexplicable
je ne sais vraiment pas quoi dire vous
savez nous voulons juste rentrer à la
maison et personne ne peut nous dire ce
que nous devons faire pour cela depuis
dimanche minuit
la france a suspendu la circulation des
personnes et des biens en provenance du
royaume uni pendant 48 heures elle
autorise à partir de ce mercredi le
retour de certains français aux
résidents français mais seulement sous
réserve de test négatif de -2 72 heures
le premier ministre britannique lui a
souhaité se montrer rassurant je tiens à
répéter que ces retards ne s'applique
qu'à un très petit pourcentage de
denrées alimentaires entrant au royaume
uni et comme l'ont dit les dirigeants de
supermarchés britannique leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement sont solides et
fiables
tout le monde peut donc continuer à
faire ses achats normalement on ignore
si la suspension des liaisons adoptée
par la france va être prolongée au-delà
des 48 heures initialement annoncé
plus de 40 pays ont déjà suspendu leurs
échanges avec le royaume uni